started with some breaking news we'll
show you the scene outside the polish
embassy
in tokyo where reports say the bella
russian sprinter christina
simenovskaya may be on her way there we
know poland had offered her
some sort of sanctuary this comes after
the police in japan and the
international olympic committee
are now protecting her she claims her
team
tried to remove her from japan against
her consent she'd voiced some concern
about what her coaches were doing she'd
done that on instagram
and of course you may remember the the
huge problems there are
in belarus at the moment that disputed
election last year and now the brother
of the president
is head of the bella russian olympic
committee so the
real concern she has in in being forced
to return
to minsk let's get the latest from tom
parmenter who's in tokyo
for us this morning and the fact this is
moving quite quickly now tom
yeah as far as we understand it she's
still at the international airport here
in tokyo hanida airport and it's been
quite a
24 hours really for this sprinter who
should be competing in the 200 meter
event in the athletic stadium but
instead is at the airport having been
dragged out of the competition by her
coaches she says against her will and
uh she says that that's because she
spoke out on her instagram account
and was quite critical of her coaches
and said that they were negligent
she's clearly in a position of being
quite scared and vulnerable and
just very unsure that she wants to go
back to minsk and therefore
what happens next that is the big
question the olympic organizers have
someone with her
they say that she is safe and secure and
spent the night at an airport hotel
as they try to work out what is the best
path forward the polish foreign minister
as you said the polish embassy is on
alert really to see whether or not she
will
go there in tokyo as her next move the
polish foreign minister said that she
was offered a humanitarian visa
and is free to pursue her sporting
career in poland if
she so chooses so we'll watch that
situation very carefully bringing the
very latest through the rest
of the morning